Welcome to the
Pharmacology
of the Anti
-Muscarinic Agents.
These drugs occupy and
block the muscarinic
receptors of the
parasympathetic
nervous system. They
are therefore muscarinic
antagonists. Dr.
Goldstein speaking.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology.
And I'm happy to
help you with the
practice questions
as well. just
send me an email
and we will set up
a mutually convenient
appointment.
Here are the
learning objectives.
I have labeled
them to help you
see what the
point of them is.
All questions that
I write, all content
here, will apply
to these learning
objectives.
Mechanisms, Mechanisms.
Mechanisms. Structure
activity relationship
determines mechanisms
and effects.
Mechanisms of action.
Mechanisms of
adverse effects.
Mechanisms of drug
-drug interactions.
Mechanisms determine
the effects, which
determine the
therapeutic uses, which
is the whole point
of pharmacology.
We need to make sure
we understand what's
going on with adverse
effects so we can
optimize therapy for
our individual patient
and also know who
should not get it.
Here are the preparation
materials. I highly
recommend the
practice questions. In
fact, I put them under
the required section.
The practice questions
will help you
self-assess whether
or not you know and
will help you to
apply the concepts.
So I encourage you
strongly to do them
on your own. The
answers can be found
in the notes handout.
Just do a search.
Here are the links,
including ScholarRx
Brick's link, which you
may find very helpful.
And I'm supplying
some key points as
usual. You can
use these as an
introduction to the
lecture if you wish, as
review, however
you wish to use it.
I'm not going to
read it to you.
You can read very
well yourselves.
And that brings us
to the pharmacology
of the muscarinic
receptor antagonists.
The originals,
atropine and
scopolamine, come
from plant sources.
Atropa belladonna on
the left, which is
also known as deadly
nightshade. These
berries in particular
look quite inviting,
don't they? But
they are poisonous.
And we have
gymson weed on the
right-hand side that also
contains the
belladonna alkaloids.
Here are the drugs
that you should know
by name. We have
our tertiary amines
that cross the blood
-brain barrier, atropine,
scopolamine, L
-hyosiamine, benztropine,
and oxybutynin.
L-hyosiamine is
actually the levorotary
stereoisomer of
atropine, which is why
I put a star on it.
Atropine comes
in nature and
also in in
pharmaceutics as a
mixture of the dextro
and levo stereoisomers.
So the L-hyosimine
is just the levo.
It is the levo form
that has activity.
The dextro form does
not have activity. Then
we have our quaternary
amines or quaternary
ammonium compounds
that are charged.
Quaternary 4, tertiary 3.
Three bonds, four bonds.
Quaternary ammoniums are
charged and therefore
do not cross the
blood-brain barrier.
And I'm asking you to
remember these three
because they're widely
used in therapy, and
they demonstrate the
principle very well.
So, structure-activity
relationship. Why
do we learn about that?
Well, you might be
tested on the boards,
but that's not the
reason. It's because
it is the structure
that determines how
active and what activity
a drug is going to
have. In this case,
the drug needs to fit
into the muscarinic
receptor active
site and it needs
to block the agonist
from being able to
bind. So structure
activity relationship.
What's needed
for this group of
drugs needs to have
a tropane component.
We see that here,
here, and it
needs to have
a tropic acid.
So we see that
here, here, and
on these other
compounds as
well. So, the
tertiary amines,
atropine, scopolamine,
L-hyosiamine,
synthetic derivatives,
I'm not even
going to mention,
put acetylcholine
at the top, so
possibly you can
visualize how the
structures seem similar
to acetylcholine.
Acetylcholine fits
beautifully into
the site of muscarinic
receptors, of
course, it's the
neurotransmitter.
But the others
will fit, but block
acetylcholine from
activating the receptors.
Here we see our
charge on the
quaternary
ammonium compounds.
Let's take a look
at pharmacokinetics
now. Now, pharmacokinetics
matter because
we need to know how
we're getting the
drug into the patient,
where the patient,
where the drug is
distributing to. Is
it going to get
where it needs to go?
How is it metabolized?
Is it going to,
the metabolism can determine
the bioavailability
and it determines
how we're getting
the drug out of the
body along with the
excretion. Does it go
out through the kidneys
as unchanged drug?
Does it go out as
metabolites mainly?
That's going to determine
whether or not you need
to do renal dosing.
And of course, we want
to know the half-life
so we can have some
kind of idea of the
duration of action of
the drug in the body.
That's basic fundamental
pharmacology.
So atropine and
scopolamine, tertiary
amines, rapidly
and well-absorbed
from the GI
mucosal surfaces.
They, however,
are not given
****** any longer
in this country.
They're given
parenterally.
Atropine is in ophthalmic
drops, and so is
scopolamine, but I didn't
indicate that here.
The main thing that we
want to remember with
scopolamine is that
it is in a transdermal
patch. Now think
back to when we were
remembering, I asked
you to memorize about
absorption, various modes
of absorption of drugs.
Transdermal patch is
a patch that's placed
on the skin and the
drug will pass from the
patch through the skin
into the bloodstream.
and that's how it
reaches systemic levels.
To pass through
the skin, it needs
to be lipophilic.
And we know
scopolamine is
quite lipophilic.
And therefore,
it's very suitable
for a transdermal
patch. Furthermore,
the patch releases
the drug slowly,
slowly, slowly
over time so that
the blood levels
are quite even.
quite even over
time, so we don't
get these peaks
and troughs that we
would get from an
oral formulation.
Widely distributed,
so they're passing
through all of these
various barriers
and going to all
different kinds of
tissues in the body,
including the CNS.
There is extensive
hepatic first pass
effect, particularly
of scopolamine, which
has pretty low oral
bioavailability.
And atropine,
a little better
bioavailability, also
hepatic metabolism.
Atropine does exit
through the urine as
unchanged drug.
However, scopolamine has
minimal excretion in the
urine. Two differences.
Easier to remember
of a class, what
are the class effects,
and how do the different
drugs reflect those
class effects. That
way, that makes
learning a lot smaller.
Atropine, pretty
short half-life.
Transderm scope,
pretty long, about 10
hours. And remember,
this is released
slowly, gradually, over
time, and therefore,
the duration of the
patch is actually
72 hours because that
patch has a depot
amount of scopolamine
in it to allow
enough drug to be
released into the
bloodstream over that
three-day period. it.
It's not given IM or
IV in this country,
but I've given you
the half-life of IM
or 2-IV, which is
about up to four hours,
but one to four hours
as a comparison.
Now let's take a look
at the quaternary
amines, glycopyrrolate
and epitropium.
Two synthetic
quaternary amines,
different therapeutic
uses, which we'll get
to when we are there.
So they are polar, so
of course you understand
by now that they
really have poor absorption
across membranes.
Now, that said,
glycopyrrolate
happens to be oral.
Well, how does that
make sense? Well,
there's some
absorption, not very
much, and they dose
it so that enough of
the drug gets into
the bloodstream.
They're also Ipertropium
and glycopyrrolate
are given by inhalation
also by injection.
We'll see how that
matters when we get to
the therapeutic uses.
They do not cross the
blood-brain barrier.
Low bioavailability I
said, mainly unchanged
drug in the urine,
some unabsorbed drug.
If we see an oral drug
with poor absorption,
where is it going to
go? It's not being
absorbed, it's just
going to go out the way
it came in. Well, not
exactly the way it came
out. It's going to
go out the other end.
And their half
-lives did depend
actually on the
specific product.
Basic pharmacokinetic
principles.
All right, mechanisms.
So since the beginning
of pharmacology
understanding, modern
pharmacology understanding,
they've been
categorized as
competitive antagonists
at muscarinic receptors.
This picture right
here, here's our
acetylcholine. It would
normally occupy this
spot, activate the
muscarinic receptor.
But atropine and
scopolamine, according
to this cartoon,
fit right in there.
Acetylcholine can't
get in. Of course,
these are reversible,
competitive
antagonists. They can
be out-competed if
acetylcholine levels
are high enough.
By the same token,
if the, let's say,
atropine levels are
high enough, they
can out-compete
acetylcholine, and we'll
see why that matters.
Now, more
recently, in the
pharmacology learning,
according to what
the investigators
are finding,
many of them have been
identified as
inverse agonists.
so I'm sure you
remember inverse agonist
I put this chart here
to help you visualize
it again the
inverse agonist will
bind to the active site
and will has affinity
only for the active
site as an antagonist
and will reduce
the basal effect I
want you to just
basically remember
those two two
different concepts.
These include
atropine, apretropium,
glycopyrrolate, a
whole bunch of them.
So it's easier to
group it, remember
the group, than to
remember the individual
names. I do not
have stars on these.
So you don't
have to remember
those by name
at this point.
okay so if we give
the drug what response
do we expect to see
well the first way to
be able to predict
the response of an
antagonist is to think
about what does the agonist
do so thinking about
the cholinomimetics
we think about the
effects on the heart
and we think about
drip drip drip Correct?
So the antagonists
are going to
do the opposite.
Dry, dry, dry.
Salivary and lacrimal
glands decrease
elevation and
tearing. Dry mouth,
dry eyes. Only makes
sense. Correct?
Sweat glands. It's
going to block
sweating. Decrease
sweating. What's
going to happen
when we decrease
sweating? We get
hot dry skin.
Sweating is one of
our thermoregulatory
mechanisms. It helps
us cool off. So these
drugs are going to
block that cooling off
mechanism and as a
result hyperthermia
may result. So who is
at the highest risk?
Children.
Also older individuals.
eyes what normally
happens well meiosis
and accommodation
to near vision
we're blocking
that we're blocking
meiosis what's going
to happen we're
going to get the
sympathetic effect
unopposed and so
it's going to cause
increased size of
the pupil medriasis
and it's going to
prevent the lens from
shaping into the
accommodating shape and
so we get cycloplegia,
that's called.
Unable to focus on near
things, near vision.
What happens?
Blurred vision.
What's happening
in the lungs? Well,
drip, drip, drip,
it's going to decrease
the respiratory
secretions, but also
it's going to block
bronchoconstriction by
histamine, bradykinin,
nycocinoids, all those
things. and it will
allow unopposed beta
-adrenergic bronchodilation.
And this is a key
mechanism that we will
talk about more later
on in this lecture.
It's a desirable effect.
Cardiovascular.
Well, if we activate
M2 receptors in
the heart, that will
slow the heart rate.
So what happens
when we block them?
We get an increase
in the heart rate,
tachycardia even.
In the AV node,
we get enhanced
conduction in the
AV node. Oh, so
what is this
thing below here?
Paradoxical
bradycardia. How
in the world
does that happen?
Well, we're going
to talk about that.
And that is something
that this concept
is something you
really need to know.
It's clinically
important, and
they like to test
it on the boards.
What's happening in the
gastrointestinal system?
Well, drip, drip,
drip is what
happens when we activate
acetylcholine
receptors in the gut.
We get the opposite
with these drugs.
So we're going to
inhibit smooth muscle
contractions, so
inhibit motility.
Remember, rest
and digest,
that's the
cholinomimatic effect.
So we're blocking that.
We get delayed
gastric emptying,
constipation, and
inhibition of gastric
secretion. So
all the opposite
things from what
acetylcholine does.
Urinary tract,
relaxing smooth muscle
of the bladder wall.
So that's called
the detrusor muscle.
And that will
slow voiding, possibly
interrupt voiding,
possibly cause
urinary retention.
It inhibits the
urethral smooth muscle
relaxation, and
that's going to
contribute to urinary
retention as well.
In the CNS,
for those that
cross the blood
-brain barrier,
like atropine
and scopolamine,
euphoria,
drowsiness,
antero-grade amnesia,
so forgetting
amnesia being
forgetting anything
that happened after
the drug hit the
CNS, fatigue and
dreamless sleep.
Euphoria, *****
potential of these drugs,
especially start thinking
about the plants,
gymson weed, for example.
Okay, dose-related
effects of atropine.
dose related effects
is an essential
concept to understand
with all drugs but
with atropine in
particular and this
is really a good
example of what happens
when drug drug
doses are increased
at low doses of
atropine there's going
to be a little
cardiac slowing
slowing so this
is the paradoxical
bradycardia which is
an undesirable thing
cardiac slowing
with that low dose
get some dryness of
the mouth inhibition
of sweating those
are seen fairly
early we can
see with the low
dose double the dose
to one milligram
more dry mouths patient
feels thirsty because
the mouth is so dry
heart rate increases
so now we're starting
to see we're moving
towards tachycardia
mild dilation mild
dilation of the pupils
double the dose again
now the heart is really
pounding pump pump
pump pump that's what
palpitations are the
patient can actually
feel that heart pounding.
Mouth is really dry.
Pupils are dilated.
And as a result,
there's some
cycloplegia and
blurred vision.
Now, much bigger dose,
five milligrams,
more than double.
Really get
marked symptoms.
Heart. Heart is
pounding away. Mouth is
really dry. Pupils
are dilated. Vision is
blurred. Patient is
starting to slur a little
bit, difficulty speaking,
hard to swallow,
feeling restless
and tired, fatigued,
headache. Now we have
this hot, dry skin,
difficulty in urinating,
and the intestinal
peristalsis is
starting to slow down.
This is a
really big dose,
10 milligrams or
more. We like to
avoid that if
necessary, if possible.
Sometimes it's
necessary, though.
Really marked symptoms.
Pulse is just
flying away.
Iris is practically
obliterated
by that large pupil.
Very blurry vision.
Skin is flushed
now. And this
is called atropine flush.
Something you
should not forget.
This term you should
not forget. Why is
the skin flushed?
Because the body is doing
what it can to try
and cool down, which
means capillaries at
the surface of the
skin are opening up.
And so that makes
the skin look flushed.
hot dry scarlet
skin that's why it's
called atropine flush
difficulty walking
in a straight line
restless excited
now there are
hallucinations
delirium seizures and
coma you see dose
dependent effects to
very serious effects
toxic effects
and we'll get back
to this concept
with our anticholinergic
toxidrome.
Let's talk about
the paradoxical
bradycardia for a moment.
This is a transient
effect. It's very
brief, but it
can be clinically
important. This
happens with the low
-dose IV atropine I
mentioned before.
so normally we know
that acetylcholine
will activate the m2
receptors and cause
bradycardia well with
this low dose this
is the theory actually
the atropine may
block the inhibitory
action and as a
result that will cause a
release of acetylcholine
and that will slow
the heart rate
now the higher doses
will block the m2
effects on the sa node
and parasympathetic
effects that will
cause tachycardia so
how is this mitigated
how do we mitigate
this initial paradoxical
bradycardia if
we're giving this
to a patient with
bradycardia we don't
want to make it worse
usually we don't give
drugs by rapid IV
injection but if this
if the appropriate
dose is given by a
rapid intravenous
injection by people
who are trained in this
then that can bypass this
transient bradycardic
effect so I have
some pictures here
what it might look
like in the left eye.
See this pupil is
much larger here than
this pupil and it
remains dilated
after installation
of 1% pylacarpine in
the left eye. So
pylacarpine is the
cholinomimetic but
its effects blocked.
And because the
atropine is there, and
therefore the pupil
will not shrink in size.
All right, let's talk
about therapeutic
uses. What are we
using these drugs for?
Atropine pre-anesthesia.
So when anesthesia
is administered,
that can stimulate
the salivary and
respiratory tract secretions
and also can cause
some bradycardia.
So by giving a
dose of atropine,
that can prevent all
of these salivary
and respiratory
secretions and
also prevent
the bradycardia.
We'll be talking
about these drugs,
neostigmine and
pyridostigmine, which
are called
cholinesterase inhibitors
in, oh, we've talked
about it already,
no, in the next
lecture, excuse me.
Prior to administration
of these two drugs
to reverse, which can
reverse the muscarinic
side effects of those
drugs, so they're
cholinesterase
inhibitors, so they're
cholinomimetics, it's
true, we did talk
about it already,
which will cause the
the acetylcholine
effects so by giving
atropine that's
going to block those
this is patient specific
this is procedure
specific this is
physician practitioner
specific i'm just giving
you generalizations
so cardiovascular
short-term intervention
for persistent
bradyarrhythmia due to high
vagal tone. It makes sense
if the bradyarrhythmia
is due to high vagal
tone and atropine
will act on muscarinic
receptors on on
the vagus nerve. It
makes sense to use it.
Reversal agent,
cholinergic poisoning to
block the effects of
acetylcholine actions in
the CNS so that's
going to need the big
bigger dose and the
periphery scopolamine is
only available in the
transdermal patch as I
mentioned before there's
a picture of it it's
this dot right here
dot looks like a band
-aid to me anyway to
prevent motion sickness
so it acts scopolamine
acts on muscarinic
receptors in the
vestibular system. It will
block the effect of
acetylcholine there,
and that really helps
with motion sickness
prevention. Once the
motion sickness is active
and the person is
vomiting, it's a little
too late. So we use it
for prevention. Also
prevention of post-op
nausea and vomiting,
control of
excessive salivation
and neuromuscular
diseases. So it
does have its
place in therapy.
Now, I mentioned
the quaternary
ammonium compounds,
istrotropium,
tiotropium, and
glycopyrrolate.
We'll look at ipratropium
and tiotropium first.
These are available
only by oral inhalation.
And it's in nebulizer,
but I've given
you a metered dose
inhaler picture here.
so it's sprayed into
the mouth and breathed
into the lungs so that
it acts locally on
bronchial tissues and
by doing it this way
there can be a large
concentration of the drug
in the bronchial
tissues where it can act
on bronchial smooth
muscle it has very poor
absorption into the
bloodstream so we avoid
the systemic adverse
effects that we would
normally have if we
gave it systemically.
Sama is a short
-acting muscarinic
antagonist. Lama
is a long-acting
muscarinic antagonist,
which is why I put
a star on both
of those. But you
notice that it says
tropium on the end.
It's going to be
an anti-muscarinic
agent that's used
for oral inhalation.
So basically, what
is it doing? It's
just blocking the
muscarinic receptors
on bronchial smooth
muscle. So it's
preventing atropine
from causing
constriction of that
smooth muscle. And it's
also acting on the
mucus receptors.
But the main point
of these drugs is
constriction of the
bronchial smooth muscle.
Four, management of
chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease
like chronic
bronchitis emphysema
and for asthma.
They're usually
not used alone.
We'll talk more
about that later on.
And ipratropium also
comes in a nasal
spray, so intranasal
use for a runny nose.
Glycopyrrolate now.
This one is used
like atropine, but it
does not cross the
blood-brain barrier.
I'll just put BBB and
an X through it. Does
not cross the blood
-brain barrier,
therefore is not
likely to cause the CNS
adverse effects. So it
can be used for induction
of anesthesia
and intubation,
intraoperative use for
the blocking the vaguely
mediated bradycardia,
reduces salivary
and bronchial secretions,
GI secretions.
So same uses, just with
the extra advantage
of not crossing the
blood-brain barrier.
There's one little extra
here, comes in these
topical forms and
also ******, remember,
Oral has still
got very low
bioavailability. It's
actually about 3%.
But they dose it
in such a way to
achieve adequate
systemic levels.
Hyperhidrosis is
excessive sweating.
Well, now we have
some other ones here
that I mentioned
in the beginning.
Oxybutanin is an
antispasmodic for the
symptomatic relief of
overactive bladder.
And this is something
that usually
happens to older women,
mainly, not only.
It's moderately selective
for M3 receptors,
which is good. That's
what we're targeting
on an overactive
bladder, on bladder
tissue. It's still only
moderately selective.
It's going to be kind of
a dose-dependent issue.
Excessive hepatic
metabolism. Here we
have our CYP3A4.
Remember, CYP3A4 has
approximately 50
% of the CYP-Pi in
terms of the drugs that
it will inactivate,
or I should say
will metabolize.
oxybutynin does have
a high incidence of
anti-muscarinic side
effects well yeah
that's what we expect
here's our l-hyothiamine
some some of you
may know it as
lebsin and it is really
used for visceral
spasms belly spasms
there are a couple of
others that are used
i've indicated them
here. I don't have
stars on them though.
Benztropine and
triaxifenadol,
Parkinson's disease
to manage the tremors.
You'll learn about
Parkinson's disease in
later lectures and
I'll leave it at that.
Ophthalmic products,
atropine, homoatropine,
cyclopentylate,
tropicamide, they all
do the same thing.
The only difference is
their duration of
action. that cause
medriasis and cycloplegia.
And so they're used
by ophthalmologists
for various reasons.
Here's a summary of the
therapeutic uses
by organ system.
As physicians,
as healthcare
professionals, We
tend to think about
drug use according
to what the patient
presents with,
so organ systems.
And I'm not going
to go through this.
This is just rehashing
what we talked
about, but in a
different context.
Adverse effects resulting
from muscarinic blockade.
I put it in this
little flow chart.
Muscarinic blockade
causes CNS effects
if they cross
the blood-brain
barrier. And what are
those CNS effects?
Dizziness, cognitive
impairment
like confusion,
delirium,
and scopolamine
specifically causes CNS
effects at therapeutic
doses. Remember we talked
about atropine,
where the lower doses
really do not have much
effect on CNS systems.
But it certainly does
at the higher doses.
Well, scopolamine has CNS
effects as
therapeutic doses.
Why?
Well, it's structure,
number one. So
why do we use it as
for motion sickness?
So it's got to
get into the CNS
in order to work to
prevent vomiting.
they cause thick
respiratory secretions
and plugging the
systemic drugs
the inhaled ones
don't seem to cause
that important
difference they cause
they decrease
motility of the gut
motility of the GI system
and hot, dry skin by
suppression of
thermoregulation.
There is an
FDA warning on
transdermal scope
about hyperthermia
resulting in
hospitalization
that has occurred in
young people, children
and adolescents, and
those older adults.
It is a FDA warning.
It's called black box
warning and that's just
what people call it.
Contraindications.
Well first of all
let me say atropine
is not contraindicated
in anybody in cases
of organophosphate
toxicity because
that is life
-threatening, and
atropine is needed.
So let's get back to
the contraindications.
Narrow-angle glaucoma.
What's happening? We
use the drug. It causes
that pupil to really
dilate, and that may
block the filtration
angle. Oops, I'm going
to make a very bad
eye here, and here's the
nose, and this is the
angle we're talking
about where the canal
of Schlem is, and if we
have a very big pupil,
that's going to close
off this spot, and
that can increase the
intraocular pressure.
Prostatic hyperplasia
can aggravate or
even precipitate
urinary retention. What
are we thinking about
here? Somebody goes
in for some kind
of surgery is given
atropine to prevent
the secretions, prevent
aspiration of those
secretions, and
after the surgery
comes out with urinary
retention, which
means a leg bag might
be necessary. A
catheter and a leg bag.
Cardiovascular
disease, tachycardia.
Okay, tachycardia,
what's happening
there? The heart is
beating fast, faster.
And if it's beating
faster, it's using,
needs more oxygen.
It's working harder.
And in patients who
have ischemic heart
disease, where those
coronary arteries are
occluded partially
or even completely,
that can precipitate
an ischemic attack,
even myocardial infarcts
and a heart attack,
or possibly arrhythmia.
All dangerous.
Gastrointestinal
obstruction. Anybody
who's got a paralytic
ileus or severe
ulcerative colitis,
because inhibiting
the GI motility
can aggravate
these conditions.
It's all so logical.
It's all, I'm sure
you can see that it's
all related to the
mechanism of the drug,
the effects of the
drug, and the effects
it has on these various
systems in patients
who are at risk for
the adverse effects.
okay let's talk
about the Toxidrome
Toxic Syndrome Toxidrome
is a portmanteau
they all make sense
now that we know what
the adverse effects are
and the mechanism so
a rapid and weak pulse
that heart is just
beating like mad iris
practically obliterated
so the vision is blurred,
and the cycloplegia.
Skin is flushed, hot,
dry, and scarlet.
Ataxia, restlessness,
excitement,
hallucinations, delirium,
seizures, coma. Of
course, dose dependent.
And I have the whole
toxidrome mnemonic
on the next slides.
But let's talk about
reversal first.
Phisostigmine. I'm
sure you remember
phisostigmine. This
is the cholinomimetic
cholinesterase
inhibitor, cholinesterase
inhibitor that
crosses the CNS.
Okay, so we're talking
about the adverse
effects of atropine
toxicity, which means it's
a high dose, which
means it's gotten into
the CNS, which makes
sense that if we want
to reverse agents,
reverse the toxic effects
in the CNS, we need
something that will
get in there and
outcompete the atropine.
So that would
be fisostigmine.
However, fisostigmine
itself has adverse
effects, and its use
is controversial.
And certainly,
only people who
are experienced
with the use of
phisostigmine
should ever use it.
For most patients with
anticholinergic toxicity,
supportive therapy
alone is adequate.
This is going to be
based on individuals.
Contraindication
of phisostigmine.
drugs that are not after
pain that also have
those anti-muscarinic
effects these fysostigmine
is contraindicated
with these toxicities
tricyclic antidepressants
you'll learn
about those later
phenylstiazine derivatives
antipsychotics you'll
learn about those later
antihistamines first
generation these all
also have anti-muscarinic
effects in addition
to their therapeutic
action bisostigmine
can exacerbate the
adverse effects because
these drugs have all
kinds of different
effects not just anti
-muscarinic effects
and that can lead to
severe complications.
Okay, mnemonic, and I
have pictures on the
next slide if you'd
like to move your vision
down to it while I
talk about it. Red is a
beat, dry is a bone,
blind is a bat, hot is
Hades, mad is a hatter,
the bowel and bladder
lose their tone, and
the heart runs alone.
That one's a
later edition by
somebody. I like it,
so I added it too.
Red is a beat.
Let's go to
the Next slide.
Red as a beet. This
is the atropine
flush. This is a
scarlet skin. Hot,
dry, scarlet skin.
Dry as a bone.
All those secretions
are inhibited.
Blind as a bat because of
medriasis and
cycloplegia.
Hot as Hades because
of hyperthermia,
tachycardia, hypertension,
and mad as a hatter.
Here's the explanation
for the etiology
of that term,
Matt is a hatter.
In the past,
hatters would breathe
in the mercury fumes
from the felt they
were making, and all
that mercury could
eventually, over time,
cause psychotic
effects in the brain.
all right hair special
populations can we
use them in pregnancy
well if the person
absolutely positively
needs it as an antidote
certainly we should
give it but not as
a general statement
infants and young
children well if we have
to give it then to save
the child's life then
Absolutely, but a
patient must be in a
place where the adverse
effects, the
hyperthermia, can be
monitored for and treated
if it should appear.
And, of course, elderly.
Older patients.
I prefer the word
older patients.
There seems to be
a spectrum of older
patients, young
older patients,
medium older patients,
and very older patients.
Susceptible to both
peripheral and
CNS effects.
The point I want
to make here, and
this is true with
so many drugs.
Drugs with
anticholinergic effects
should be
avoided in older
individuals because
the side effects of
the drugs outweigh
the benefits.
The drugs can cause
impaired cognition
and confusion
and psychoses,
imagine that in the
person who already
has dementia can
lead to falls.
Elderly people tend
to have worse balance,
tend to fall more
easily. So these drugs
really should be
avoided. Not the inhaled
ones. They don't get
into the bloodstream.
They're safe in
the older person
as well as the
younger person.
So a few thought
questions.
I'll read them to
you and invite you to
pause your computer
and think about them.
Pause your video, I mean.
A hospitalized
patient is diagnosed
with symptomatic
sinus bradycardia.
What drug can
be administered?
The drug is
administered by rapid
IV push to avoid
a specific adverse
effect. What
is that adverse
effect than the
proposed mechanism.
And Jannie is
a 38-year-old
woman prone to
car sickness.
She places a small
patch that looks like
a round band-aid
behind her ear the day
before she and a
companion are leaving for
a road trip across
country. What is the
drug? Other than
convenience, what is an
advantage of this route
of administration?
So, if you wish, now's
a good time to pause.
Okay so let's talk
about the answers.
Atropine is the drug.
It blocks the vagal
effects that normally
slow the heart
rate which is which
allows unopposed
sympathetic nervous
system stimulation. That's
where the increased
heart rate comes from
resulting in increased
heart rate and
improved conduction
through the AV node.
The drug is administered
by rapid IV push
to mitigate any
potential for paradoxical
bradycardia. The
initial low dose of
atropine from a slow
intravenous injection
may initially block
inhibitory presynaptic
receptors, causing
acetylcholine
release, thus slowing
the heart rate. So, rapid
IV administration
avoids this effect.
And now we have
Jannie, who's
going on a road
trip, and she places
a small patch
behind her ear.
Transdermal scopolamine
bypasses first-pass
metabolism and maintains
steady, consistent
blood levels and avoids
peaks and troughs.
Avoiding high peak
concentrations
may reduce dizziness and
drowsiness and
other side effects.
Plus, she has the
convenience of wearing it
for three days before
having to remove it.
And an otherwise
healthy 77-year-old
female presents to
the family practice
clinic with signs
and symptoms of
respiratory infection
that would likely
respond to a
macrolide antibiotic.
The patient takes
oxybutynin for urinary
incontinence due
to bladder spasms.
Which macrolide
antibiotics would lead to
an increase in the
anti-muscarinic side
effects of oxybutanin?
Okay, I know you
haven't had macrolide
antibiotics. If you want,
you can set this one
aside until later.
Or you can say
to yourself,
well, I can at least
come up with the
mechanism of the drug
interaction. I've
given you a hint. It
is a pharmacokinetics
-related mechanism.
And then the next
question is, a 62
-year-old male ******
diagnosed with COPD
is given prescriptions
for a LAMA, of course
our acronyms became
pronounced words, and
a SABBA, and guidance
for smoking cessation.
What are the
drugs and how will
a patient take them?
If you'd like to
think about it for a
moment, it would be
a good time to pause.
So the mechanism of
this pharmacokinetic
mechanism of drug
interactions is CYP3A4.
I will be mentioning
CYP3A4 many
times in this
particular block of
pharmacology. Erythromycin
and clorithromycin
are strong CYP3A4
inhibitors.
So we already
learned about
this metabolism in CYPs.
So inhibiting CYP3A4
is going to inhibit
the metabolism of
oxybutanin, which will lead
to increased levels
of oxybutanin in the
bloodstream. And we
remember that oxybutynin
is a muscarinic
antagonist. It's got
some selectivity for
M3 receptors, but as
concentrations go up,
selectivity goes down.
And the drug will have a
myriad of side effects.
A 62-year-old male
****** diagnosed
with COPD. Okay,
he's given a Lama
and a Lassaba.
So what are they?
Tiotropium is the
long-acting anti
-muscarinic drug and
our antagonist, and
that's used for maintenance
of bronchodilation.
It's long-acting. It
has a long duration
of activity. It will
continue to block
the cholinergic
bronchoconstriction. Okay,
so that's going to allow
unopposed activation
of beta-2 receptors
on bronchial smooth
muscle, which will
cause bronchodilation.
So the patient is
given a short-acting
beta agonist,
albuterol, for direct
stimulation of the
beta-2 receptors.
We'll talk about this
in the next lecture.
and this is going to
cause bronchial smooth
muscle relaxation
and bronchodilation
so you get these two
actions working in
concert with each other
causing a sustained
bronchodilation and
allowing easier breathing
for patients who
have COPD or asthma.
And a 30 year old
female presents to
the in emergency
department with confusion,
delirium, hot
flush dry skin,
dilated pupils,
tachycardia, hypotension,
conduction anomalies,
and absent,
it should be
hypertension.
I just noticed that.
Hypertension,
conduction anomalies,
and absent bowel
sounds. She
has a seizure
while in the ED.
Her roommate shows the
health care team an
empty prescription vial
labeled amitriptyline
50 milligrams daily
and dated yesterday
so amitriptyline
is a tricyclic
antidepressant it's got
atropine like or anti
-muscarinic activity which
is not its main main
pharmacologic therapeutic
effect why should
the reversal agent
for anti-muscarinic
toxic toxicity be
avoided in this patient
Overdose, bi-tricyclic
antidepressants,
or phenothiazine
derivatives, or other
drugs that have
anticholinergic
actions, have a wide
range of adverse
effects, including
cardiac toxicity.
Physo-stigmine can
exacerbate them
and lead to severe
complications.
A 20-year-old pregnant
female agricultural
worker is brought to
the emergency room.
with confusion and
other signs and symptoms
of cholinergic toxicity
consistent with
poisoning by insecticides.
Her co-worker reports
that carbamate, not
organophosphate,
insecticides were used.
She is treated with
decontamination, respiratory,
and cardiovascular
support. What is the
reversal agent and
should it be administered
to this patient?
The reversal agent
is atropine. Now
remember, pralidoxime
is not indicated
because it's not
organophosphate poisoning,
and pralidoxime is
not effective against
poisoning bicarbamate
insecticides.
And yes, atropine
could be administered
because it is life
-threatening and the
benefit far outweighs
any risk to the fetus.
And here's our
summary, which I
won't go through
and read it to you.
I hope it's
helpful to you.
And here are
the Check Your
Knowledge questions
and answers.
And thank you very much.
Thank you.